hello and welcome to this video playing
bones this is Grand Master Hung Kai
let's go from germany is playing quite a
lot recently the third game in a
relatively short time span a bit
surprised about is opening that's not
what it usually does ok so the normal
way of planes is to push the five early
i think i will do that here even though
it's not a completely standard type of
position with this early c6 plate but
still it looks right grab space and
later try to make use of the the open e
file the question is how do i play from
here yeah maybe i am directly go for
this in bishop f3 not entirely sure what
the most precise move water is bishop
belongs on III of course then bishop to
f3 moon hmm taking with the night is not
completely I'm completely out of the
picture
hmm it's an interesting way to play
maybe try that just trying to use that
diagonal here as its to make it an open
diagonal not have a pawn on d5 the only
thing that it's looking a bit wrong as
it takes quite a bit of time and could
be a bit slow possible Knight e5 is
varying me it's centralized and so that
97 as possible so no Knight a5 my
development is lacking here really is
now I could cheat with the Queen yeah
but I don't see a big point then I don't
know that taking with the night was very
time consuming so maybe this is the
drawback of my approach yeah that's the
issue
now I have to do something like that
something active okay if I take a seven
there is possibly be six but
I can take B sound them
why it doesn't look great but it is not
a good position anyway so what now
Bishop to a six maybe now rather go here
if he takes III with the night at least
it trades down to opposite colored
bishops which isn't it's still not great
but what can you do as simply misplaced
okay so i could take a seven year or
what is the deal i use got rocked it to
one that case
maybe I have up still empty too
okay come on it's bad anyway maybe this
is at least a bit confusing the rook
doesn't have many squares yeah it still
has enough pull pretty bad game oh my
I can just take a to hear that also wins
out no doubt but I thought you just take
a two okay what the heck yeah that idea
of taking on 25 with the piece was just
as bad yeah with hindsight I'm just too
far behind in development you know just
play normal stuff see takes 25 widest
slightly better as usual in this
position that's actually very
comfortable line for what so there's no
need to be creative I just wanted to try
something else
hoping for Queen age three but it's a
very vague hope might happen and still
can always hope
John Bishop t2 wasn't a very successful
idea okay so Queen age 3 is got Luke h8
I guess time warning
check at least I've got this check here
which in itself isn't great but a screen
asics check unfortunately I couldn't you
just win light easily and not give me
hope I mean okay it's probably stuck a
totally lost but it felt it could have
been easier you have three looks
terrible anyway narrow gauge to is so
simple we know okay how was that there
is an absolutely atrocious game yeah it
was it was a bad idea to take with the
night I guess after this we got a
standard position that is slightly
slightly better for white it's it's
coming from various move waters of that
d6 Bishop g4 complex by displaying this
this which should be three queen bee
three and you enjoyed the bishop I was
just thinking that this could be
interesting try to get the bishop open
down but only three bad just it just
takes far too long this is probably i
don't know maybe as soon as i can store
take with the pond even though that this
is this is a less-attractive version of
course and yeah i'm just in bad shape
yeah my development is too bad it's just
too bad TM probably scared I'm just
losing him and wasn't the toughest way
to defend was then yeah well I mean it
was always winning for him I was just
wondering if it could have been be done
quick quick of it there's nothing that I
can do him yeah okay the moral of the
story is don't be
creative if you know a simple way
forward that is good yeah yeah just this
next time and I'm certainly okay yeah
the reason why this is a bit better for
wide is that we get this in like the
ship here rookie one you see a seven is
always a little bit sensitive and Bishop
only three years putting pressure on the
queenside black has very little active
that he can do he's got a position that
is quite compact doesn't have s not
exposed himself with big weaknesses or
so but he has absolutely no big chances
of getting anything active going so it
was rather comfortable for me okay well
thanks for watching